[Music]
foreign
I think it was like your last Netflix
special it was really a joy for me man
to to watch that and to me from like an
outsider it seems like that's easier for
you making yourself almost like the butt
of the joke yes and and and but that's
also I think what you're saying has like
caused you a [__] ton of [__] pain or
a [__] ton of like feeling betrayed or
feeling like anger whatever that is
um I started doing comedy
and you know I didn't have many friends
I had like two that I would hang out
with or my mom
I think I was like I can make fun of
myself better than all of you like
like you know you know and it became
sort of this like it made me feel like
Teflon because you know I was just like
whatever joke you say I I have a better
one about myself and also you're doing a
station you're getting some sort of
positive positive feedback and just like
you know when you I'm the first person
to laugh you know at myself and when you
do that it opens up the crowd to okay so
he's not taking himself too seriously it
it's just like an approach for comedy
that I think I like like my favorite
stand-ups do that like Burr Chappelle
Eddie like all these guys they tell
personal I love one-liners I love Rodney
but like you know I don't know anything
about him after the thing right aside
from like you know yeah yeah and I love
that yeah but like my the people I I
like to like know them and I'm like that
way you hear their next special they're
talking about their wife you remember
from the other one and like you grow
with these artists you know same with
like music you love their story whatever
so I always loved that style of
Storytelling
um and I felt that you could
not get away with more but you can if if
you you know shoot yourself in the foot
first and then it opens up for you to
have you know people are more receptive
to hearing what you have to say because
you're not you know coming from an ego
standpoint it's an egoless standpoint
it's more of just like hey this is an
idea this is fun I'm just trying to have
fun so that's why I always took that
approach and then you know because of
the way my career turned out and the
things that happened it just opened the
floodgates and it turned on me and now
the last couple years I've just been
trying to dial it back where like I
don't want to not be open I love talking
to people I love connecting with people
some of the best conversations I've had
I've been at like bus stations with
random dudes that are like hey I saw
this weird thing you spoke about
whatever and then that's like why you do
it you know that's like what makes you
happy like oh I'm so glad I did that I
don't know why I was questioning myself
for doing that
um but you know now I'm trying to just
share when it feels appropriate or to
share I don't feel like I have I owe
anyone anything sure but um there is
that certain element of like you know
now because of the internet you sort of
feel like you do have to kind of defend
yourself a little bit where you're like
hey man like
no you know so it's a tricky situation
to be in because you don't want to come
across as whiny or not grateful because
I'm very grateful on our own change of
[__] decision I made because I love
the lessons I was taught uh the people
I've met I'm not mad at anyone I don't I
hold any anything on anyone I think
everyone's just trying their best and
you know so that's just how I'm trying
to live my life but it's it's a hard
it's a hard thing to navigate because
you'll do something and then somebody
will do something you'll be like hey and
they're like well you'd [__]
did a movie about your life that you did
that's right and you're like
all right yeah I get it I get it you
know so that's why I'm trying to like
you know just act be an actor if in
something and not just be what people
think is me the right though like you'll
show up to set and you're playing
yourself and they're like hey I'm a big
idiot with a dick that smokes weed
you're like Jesus Christ this is what
Oscar winners think of me yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
that's humiliate like oh my God like you
do it because you want them to like you
and you want to work with people and
that was my thing for a bit but it
doesn't have to be my thing forever and
as I grow and learn it's one of your
things bro yeah there's one in your
thing yeah like it's someone you're
right and I mean like I think that like
the genius was like oh it's like but I
get I I guess it's like to think that
that doesn't come out of cost and what I
really like it's like that 911 thing
John like people be like oh he's
probably just talking about his dead dad
all the time it's like yo I made two
jokes about my dad in a span of like 15
years like to act like I'm just like
this like feel bad for me my dad like
that's just such [__] and it makes
me feel like like so small and shitty
and like I'm trying to share little
jokes here and there about them because
like I like to keep that memory alive my
dad was a great dude like why is that a
[__] problem and like it I get
defensive it's my family you know like
anybody who's like [__] risked
anything as a [__] artist like to
understand the boldness again and The
Bravery to to [__] do that like going
to that go into that spot it's like like
I really [__] admire and commend the
[__] out of you for doing and you when
you do you you're still going to go
inward right I mean like it's always
going to go inward but I think I I think
there's a place for everything and now I
learned that like okay me on stage with
a microphone where I have full control
and I could tell what I have the way I
want to tell it that's the spot because
that's my stand up that's what I that's
the outlet I want for it and I guess the
the struggle or like where I'm dealing
with it and I'm getting better at is
like you gotta just let people talk
until you get you get to yeah and your
moment will come and it's about patience
and that's like something I'm not good
at it's like being patient and you can't
please everyone you can't fix every
little thing some people are gonna think
things that they heard on a website or
saw in a [__] thing or someone's
brother told them or whatever and
there's nothing you could [__] do
about it yeah the only thing you can
control is like
who you have around you so what you put
your energy into and like who loves you
and who you love back and that's
something like it's a hard thing to it's
like a weird thing for me to even grasp
now because like I've lived in
discomfort for so long where that became
comfortable so now I actually have
people around me that love me and it's
weird
and it's that's that's like a whole new
thing I never thought of it's like oh
it's weird can you explain that
weirdness we're being happy it's weird
like being like I was like at home the
other day and I was talking to my girl
and my friends and I was like I feel
[__] like weird like something like
wrong and they're like what I'm like
nothing's wrong yeah what is that is
that like a peace of mind is that I
don't know what I think I just like
look I hate to be that guy that's like
anytime something looks up some because
everybody gets kicked in the dick and
everyone gets kicked in the dick it's
the biggest to them because it's their
life so no one's struggle is bigger than
anyone's because it's theirs you know no
matter what the magnitude of who you are
or whatever it hurts just as much okay
so like I I believe like everyone's
struggle is very big to them and I just
I like was just like crying I was just
like I I always feel like the walls are
going to close in or something's gonna
be ripped out and
um I've been doing a lot of therapy like
trauma therapy trying to figure out why
I think there's obvious reasons why with
the PTSD from childhood or whatever and
the sentence that like
we've my therapist and I have agreed on
is like my dad told me he was going to
pick me up from school on 9 11. I got
picked up by my mom she didn't tell me
what was going on for like three days
and she kept telling me Dad's at work
coming home whatever I had no idea and
then I watched I was my mom was like
you're just grounded you're not allowed
to watch TV and I was like what I didn't
do anything and then one night I turned
on the TV and I just saw my dad on TV
and I was like oh okay and they're like
he's these are all the firemen that are
like dead and all that [__] so I was
like and then I had to talk to my mom it
was weird because like we didn't know he
was dead for like three weeks they were
finding people you know they're pulling
people out of [__] and there was just
some sort of Hope and like it was just
up and down and nobody knew how to deal
with it like my mom was [__] like 30
like she doesn't like I'm about to be I
wouldn't know what the [__] to do and I
that's why like as I get older I'm like
man my mom was awesome I was like [__]
she really loves me like damn like [__]
that was like rough so nobody knew the
right way to deal with it and you know
whether or not that's right or wrong it
still [__] a kid up or whatever so I
have this and I also have
BPD and a little PTSD mix which is
borderline personality disorder and so
the definition of that is fear of
Abandonment so you know Dad says come
and pick you up he doesn't for life I'm
just like I don't believe anyone and I'm
trying to learn how to believe people
and Hollywood isn't exactly the greatest
place to to learn that skill dude yeah
you know so like and you've been in it
for a [__] minute at starting at a
young age so I went from like traumatic
life to like new created High School
traumatic life yeah because like
Hollywood's like high school where it's
like the cool kids and the dicks and
[__] with the cool people are
actually the quiet people it's like
[__] weird and
um it's you know so now you know it's
the worst place for me to grow but I'm I
love this [__] and I'm gonna do my best
I can and just keep doing that but
that's I think where it comes from and
that's why I have a hard time trusting
and believing people and it's been an
issue throughout my whole life like it's
it's it's you know because I just
someone will tell me something and I
just it doesn't register it's starting
to with some people because they've been
around long enough yeah and can you give
me an example of that like something
that's working like a technique that
you're using or like something or just I
mean I just like I look at people's
character and you know I've never had to
I go do you have to question this person
has this person [__] you over in any
way has this person lied to you has this
person ever been anything but whatever
or if you had anything with them did you
work it out is this guy a dog is this
your dog
and that's you gotta fact check yourself
and if the facts check out you can't let
yourself think that way you actually
have to trick your brain because your
brain after a while becomes used to
trauma it becomes used to being hurt
becomes used to being [__] over so
you'll have that mentality and have that
attitude and you might even like make it
happen because you're so insecure and
you might create a problem out of
nothing and that's a lot of times that's
what's happened how do you check
yourself on that like how do you how do
you become how do you become aware of
that well it's just growth man like I
used to I I've been self-harming since I
was like a kid you know I used to like
cut and up until
nearly a year ago I used to Cod and uh
used to bang my head against walls
because like when if I couldn't deal
with something like if someone told me
something
sad or like I something that I couldn't
deal with I would like bang my head
against the wall hoping I would pass out
because I just didn't want to be in that
situation because I couldn't
handle that and like over years and
years and years it becomes less and less
and less and you have to use these
skills and this is great workbook that I
recommend it's called the DBT uh
workbook it's dialectical behavior
therapy and it teaches you these skills
like okay you want to cut right now go
take a cold shower listen to your
favorite song jerk off [__] watch a
movie like go call your friend like like
do anything do anything you can because
that feeling most of the time goes away
after like 15-20 minutes it's just you
get this surge you get this like feeling
and you got to know it's not real you
gotta you have it's [__] mind [__]
because you got to trick your brain into
being like no you're wrong you're trying
to make me feel bad you know I'm
actually good right now and it's like it
comes from this uh BPD has is very in
common with black and white thinking
which is like something
I still struggle with them I've gotten a
lot better but it's still pretty bad
where like everything's either all
amazing and everyone you're Rocky people
throwing your fruit while you run yeah
or it's the worst thing in the world
yeah and I had to learn that like if one
little thing isn't going the right way
that doesn't mean the whole ship sinks
that's right it's just like okay remove
that part and you're okay everything's
fine
but you have to learn that I I would
just lose lose it from little things and
you have to learn how to you know work
through that and the impulse like the
the impulse to do something like cut or
bang your head or something like that do
you pay attention do you sort of like in
whatever way you kind of keep account
like of the kind of situations or the
kind of triggers like what it makes you
want to do specifically how I mean I had
I had to do a bunch of [__] like when I
met John I was just coming out of like a
lot of [__] work on some like real anger
stuff I had like real problems with
violence uh growing up you know you
never lick it you know you never lick it
but like you can you get a handle on it
you can man you can and you can actually
I think even more so man I think I I
think what's so like exciting and
inspiring about it is I think you can
make it work for you I think you really
can I think you can make any I think in
any crisis there's a huge opportunity
[__] yeah man
[Music]
all right
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become a part of
this community look I already board Bam
Bam if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll
I'm gonna get a workout in a little bit
with my man Eric Linden stud coordinator
from The Punisher he's coming all the
way up because we're about to get after
it and when that's done he asked me in
the car are you gonna have my shake
ready and I know what that means am I
gonna have my son Warrior Shake they've
got the active protein but they also
have this collagen protein which is
amazing they also have the warrior blend
which is a little bit lighter if you're
trying to cut and uh I believe in it I
believe in that some Warrior stuff go to
www.sunwarrior.com
real ones
[Music]